the pixel 7 8 has more megapixels than
the 7 Pro while being cheaper and being
a lot cheaper than the iPhone 14. now
Max them out and take a bunch of photos
with all three of these phones that we
haven't seen yet and we're going to be
voting on them and here is the first
shot which one looks the best and the
worst all right I'm noticing some
differences already the one on the right
looks a little bit soft while the one in
the center is a little bit blown out but
I do like the colors and the contrast so
that's the best in the center the worst
is on the right for me the first thing I
noticed is the center one some of the
detail is blown out for me that makes it
the worst and then between the left and
the right I think I see more detail on
the left one so here are the results the
7 Pro is on the right seven eight is on
the left here and I think these look
pretty dang similar but we will have
some differences here is our next shot
and the way we are doing this is
different from before we want to make it
more interesting a little bit more fear
so the best phone gets three points the
middle gets two and the worst gets one
the results are gonna be very
interesting what do you guys think about
this the left one is definitely the
worst all the detail is all smudged and
it's almost it almost looks artifacty
and then between the center and the
right one I don't know I think the right
one looks just a little too dark
especially like up here on the roof and
stuff so I'm gonna go best to Center no
I gotta agree with Angelica the best is
in the center but I'd say the one on the
right is the worst all right the best
one both agreed Center and that is a
seven a the cheapest phone as you guys
see that was a crap the iPhone is only
12 megapixels compared to 50 and 64.
here's the next one this is an ultra
wide with tough lighting for me it's got
to be the center that's the best because
I like that it has all the colors in
there it's very sharp the one on the
left is bad because it's all blue that's
the worst to me like there's no yellow
orange at all it's just all blue well
for me I actually liked the left one I
liked that everything it was kind of
dark and all of this over here stands
out compared to the center one where
everything is brought up all our her
hair over here looks really weird and
then the right one just doesn't look as
detailed the left one looks really sharp
bam we have iPhone on the left there
being way darker than the other ones
here is the next shot this is a zoom
yeah right away the center is so soft
like there's no detail in his jacket so
that's the worst the one on the right
the left one looks sharper oh man
point this is going to be interesting
this is a hard one because only one of
these phones has a dedicated telephoto
huh the left one looks really good to me
yeah the left one that's that's got to
be the best for me Center worst left
best they agree and pixel Summit the
left one is the pixel 7A I thought I
told you guys you might be surprised I
put the crops in here because the pixel
7 has a 48 megapixel this is exactly 5x
what that lens does and it is worse here
we have our first portrait shop what do
you guys think okay the one on the right
is the worst like you got this huge
Shadow on her face you can't even see it
and it doesn't even look that blurry in
the background the one on the left is I
think blowing out like her dress here so
I think the best is the center for me
also the cutout on the left is pretty
messed up up here behind her hair over
here the sunny one looks really natural
yeah on the right I will say since you
guys voted there's cutouts that are good
cutouts that are bad all right so Center
best and another one for the seven eight
now I did update all these phones right
before taking these fake pictures so
they have the latest software very good
he here we have a food shot what's some
Chinese Chinese buffet I'm honestly
gonna say the one on the left I like how
the exposure is brought up of the plate
and you have the different colors of all
the food whatever whereas the one in the
center oh it kind of looks super red I
don't like that one so left is best
center is worse what do you think I'll
agree with you pixel 7 8 the best again
in the iPhone looking the worst very
flat and here is our first selfie a lot
of people in here this is our family
what do you guys think lots of peeps to
me the one on the right is the worst it
looks very very cool toned I don't like
that between the left and the center I
kind of like the one on the left better
the first thing I noticed is I do like
how the sky looks on the right one
however the detail on their faces in the
background are much softer and then
between the center and the left one I
like the center one the most and they
all fit in there yeah and this was not
staged I was gonna take just a regular
selfie and then more people joined in it
happens in life alright let's take a
look seven a worst the 7A has the widest
selfie camera which is nice
here's our next shot this one is a macro
immediately I really like the left one
it looks like a really really nice macro
shot everything pops out the center one
uh didn't work or something I don't know
maybe it just doesn't have a macro mode
it allows you to do it but just doesn't
look the same yep the one on the left
looks absolutely gorgeous all that bokeh
everywhere the colors super good the one
in the center not much blur you got all
the sticks everywhere all the branches
it looks ugly iPhone 14 did a great job
in the pixel just didn't want to take
that picture properly and this one has
tough Sunset lighting this is hard
they're all so similar for me the one on
the right is the best I like the overall
balance it's very sharp as well I don't
like the one in the center because his
face is all red you can see that for
sure so just less detail yeah Seven Pro
to best seven eight the worst and here
we have a portrait shot a lot of depth
there oh well the right one didn't work
seems like the center one looks really
weird and unnatural the left one looks
really good yep the left one wins for
sure the one on the right it didn't work
for portraits so yeah and it also has
like artifacty kindness too all right
and the iPhone
took the win the Seven Pro said it took
a portrait but it didn't it actually was
kind of consistent yeah that happened
last time yeah here we have this distant
shot of this amazing home I think I'm
immediately noticing the most detail on
the left one
and then the right one just looks really
faded all right the one on the right
very soft very faded and between the
left and the middle I do like the extra
contrast of the middle but Angelica is
right I do see more detail I'm choosing
left as well all right and the left is a
seven Pro that has that telephoto and I
was just honestly surprised how good the
7A does without a telephoto not as
detailed but destroys the iPhone here we
have another portrait shot backlit with
the Sun what okay it looks like the
porch is not even working on the left
and the right yeah it didn't work space
almost looks out of focus these are real
life scenarios your kid hops on you need
to grab a shot you want it to look good
this is what you get I mean to me I
choose a center I like even though yeah
I like that sun flare it looks really
cool it is a little bit too cool toned
but I would probably change it make it a
little bit more warm it's definitely the
best the one on the left I'd say is the
worst the worst there's like artifacting
in the face and stuff yeah yeah the
iPhone took the win and the interesting
thing with the iPhone is it will tell
you if the portrait mode is not working
with the little display whereas the
other ones tell you it's working and
then you just get a bad result so the
next one here is a backlit shot with a
sunset first thing I notice is all of
this artifacts over here and on the
right one while the left one looks very
clean so let's say left is the best
followed by the right yep I do notice
all that artifacts it looks terrible in
the center the one on the right almost
looks out of focus like no detail here
in his face so the left does end up
being the best even with the flaring
iPhone 14 compared to the pixels there
on the right to worst was the center
it's interesting how you guys are
agreeing a lot more this time than
before and here we have another portrait
shot once again it doesn't get yeah and
this is one that I did just without a
human subject yep it's more difficult I
mean the one on the right it pops out
yeah the one on the right looks great
and then it say the left one because it
all fits in the picture the center one's
kind of cropped yeah the left one's the
only one that fit yeah the left one does
look very detailed too so yep that's the
center worst right best and I promise
you guys I was not doing this on purpose
uh I don't think I've ever had this many
fails as far as portraits iPhone can do
it even if it's far away it didn't used
to be the case and here we have a shot
of our parents in Elon Center one I mean
is so detailed everything looks awesome
balanced yeah the dynamic range is the
best yeah I'd say the one on the right
is the worst because they kind of match
in detail not as sharp but it's kind of
underexposed and it's sure it's blue so
yeah it's a little bit darker iPhone did
a great job 7A in second place and here
we have a Ultra wide
with the sunset there I was gonna go
with the left because it's the best
exposed the color looks great but I
think it is a little bit too brought up
the one in the center is a little bit
more Moody while keeping the shirt color
decent while the one on the right it's
just kind of like way underexposed so I
think I'm gonna go with the center I
think I'm gonna go with the center too
okay you guys agree
and the 7A did a great job with the
balancing while the 14 is just too dark
and crushed and here we have a shot with
a soft lighting a cool hotel in the
background wow that left one looks
really good yeah the lights looks so
sharp and detailed the colors look
amazing the center one looks really
blurry yep that's true yeah the one on
the left you have the Highlight roll off
from the sunset like the sunset colors
are showing up the other ones no and
yeah you're right the center one is very
blurry and just missed the center and
Miss focused and you can't really tell
on the phone it's on the back uh but
when you get it up well larger you could
tell iPhone 14 beautiful color rendition
7A in second place now we're getting
into some darker lighting with the sun
going down man that right one is very
very blurry too much motion blur yeah
yep yeah there's motion blur it's kind
of dark underexposed and one on the
right is the worst I think the center
one looks the best we too yeah I like
how you could see everything
everything's properly exposed looks good
for detail
iPhone best 7 Pro the worst and this is
a 2X crop because with these large
sensors you can get a little bit closer
without needing uh the telephoto or the
super long Zoom yeah the right one
definitely looks the best and I think
the center one looks the most dark to me
it's between the middle and the right
and I do think the one on the right
looks better I like how it's a little
bit more warmer highlight roll off
everything the one on the left to me
looks very kind of artifacty blurry so
that's the worst one and the worst
interestingly the 7 Pro once again
slightly blurry when it's dark and
um the 14 just does a good job even
though it's a 12 megapixel and here we
have a portrait of an object in dark
lighting I was surprised that all the
phones took it I like the center I like
the blur I like everything the uh
contrast everything but also if you look
closely it's got the most detail here
the one on the right is just a little
bit too underexposed for me the left and
the center look very similar I think I
like the one on the left more I think
the colors are just it's a little too
brought up the center one for me and the
the right one just looks really bad in
my opinion the right one is the worst
and the iPhone is the word fail and here
we have a nighttime selfie quite dark oh
man they're all Hood not grades none of
them are good I think the right one
looks the least bad to me the one in the
center is the worst like it's all just
flat
oh yeah yeah the one on the right I'd
say does the best job here
that's the pixel 7 Pro better selfie cam
at night time here we have an ultra wide
shot of the pond and my fish the left
one is just way way too dark the other
two do better in this situation and the
other two are very very similar I think
I see more detail on the center one I'm
gonna say yep the left is just so
underexposed you can't see nothing I
like the one on the very right it's not
as blown out with like these details on
the Rocks so I like that one all right
and once again the iPhone did really bad
do you guys remember when the iPhone had
less contrast it looked more natural
than Android phones look at that and
here we have a portrait shot
side lit very tough these all look
really bad we need the iPhone 14 pro for
this yeah with that lidar sensor the
left one just looks so green and Smoky
but then the other t look really
artifacting weird both of the ones on
the right are just crushed the details
are gone especially the center I'd say
that's the worst I like the one on the
left because I know
um the light is most likely warm like
this so I like that one the best and
it's not as crushed I think I hate the
one on the left the most I think I like
the right one more all right mixed
feelings here and there you go no love
for the 7 Pro and this is a beautiful
flag that looked great to my eyes uh
this is a 2x so all the lenses are being
cropped in I mean it's the one on the
right that's the best the one on the
right is the best to me it's got the
most detail it doesn't suffer from the
flaring as much hitting the one on the
left is the best one I the center and
the right just looks so weird and
artifacty just everywhere in the fence
the level looks
not great but it looks cleaner I don't
like this middle is the worst thing
Metal's the worst yeah iPhone 14 is the
worst the pixels get some extra points
and for our last shot
this is on a tripod with
astrophotography modes I mean the left
is the best to me that's the best I like
you can see all these details the one on
the right is I'd say it's a little too
dark the one in the centers is way
brought up so pretty fake colors are
weird yeah I agree even though I'm not
voting and the left one is the pixel 7 8
even with more megapixels
Google did a great job and while these
guys are tying up their votes what I
will say is usually takes Google a long
time to optimize for their sensors you
know here we have a year and a half but
this one's brand new and I was just
really surprised looking at these how
well it did let us know below what
surprised you the most and now let's
figure out our winners Angelica so for
me the winner was the pixel 7A followed
by the pro and then the iPhone 14.
iPhone last yeah this is shocking the
pixel 7a1 by far destroyed them and it's
the cheapest one and then it was the
iPhone 14 and the pixel 7 Pro did the
worst so what do you guys think do you
guys agree with their votes
um I think I agree looking at all these
photos many times setting this up I was
disappointed by the 7 Pro and how could
Google give you a phone that is this
much less expensive it's crazy with a
new camera that looks fantastic even in
those Zoom shots it looked almost as
good super impressive as a dedicated
software telephoto lens thank you guys
for watching click that Circle above
check out our actual detailed comparison
with iPhone right over there that's been
Max Angelica and vadine and we'll see
you in the next one
foreign